اذا اقتحام جديد من القوات الاسرائيليه
للمسجد الاقصى تزامنا مع وجود مصلين
معتكفين في داخل نستمع الى صوت طبيعي
[تصفيق]
طبعا كانت اقوات الاسرائيليه بدات هذا
الاقتحام امس
واعتقلت العديد من المصلين داخل المسجد
الاقصى ومنعت صلاتهم الان نفس المشهد
يتكرر تقتحم بحات المسجد الاقصى وتمنع
المصلين من الاعتكاف كان هناك مواقف عربيه
ودوليه مندده حتى البيت الابيض عبر عن
قلقه من تطورات هذه الاحداث وشدد على
ضروره خفض التصعيد بين الفلسطينيين
والاسرائيليين وجامعه دول العربيه كذلك
سنعود الى هذه الاخبار لاحقا في سياق هذه
الساعه اذا نتابع في هذه الصور التي تردنا
الاقتحام جديد من قبل القوات الاسرائيليه
لباحات المسجد الاقصى لمنع المصلين من
الاعتكاف في هذه الليالي المباركه من شهر
رمضان الكريم
تحديدا امس طاهر يعني حدثت الاعتداءات بعد
انتهاء صلاه الفجر حيث كان هناك اقتحام
لضباط
الاسرائيليه ادوات الاسرائيليين وعناصر من
الشرطه لساحات الحرم
وكان هناك مهاجمه للمصلين الصائمين
بالاعيره المطاطيه والقنابل الصوتيه
مباشره بعد انتهاء صلاه الفجر